google glass was one of google's most
public and monumental fails of all time
coming in at fifteen hundred dollars
google glass drive to offer a hands-free
smartphone experience nearly a decade
ago
today it looks like apple might be
coming out with their own smart glasses
in the imminent future
so is apple glass destined to fail just
like google glass
well starting off most of the rumors
surrounding apple glass are just from
leakers and apple analysts
and though many of these guys like ming
chi ko have a solid track history
this isn't really concrete evidence
however there
is one piece of evidence that does make
it seem like apple is at least testing
some sort of wearable ar technology
some super smart individuals figured out
that internal builds of ios 13
contained code for something called star
tester after looking through the code
these guys were able to determine that
the start tester app allows users to
switch in
and out of a head mounted mode they were
also able to determine that apple was
testing something called starboard mode
which seems to be some sort of ar
experience considering this
it seems like apple is actually
seriously testing wearable ar technology
for the face
with that being said what will a
potential apple glass actually allow
users to do
well first of all apple glass is
expected to actually work like real
glasses
in other words apple glass can be
changed to your prescription using a
technology called
optical subassembly aside from this
apple glasses will of course sync up
with their messages email and other
notifications
so that you can see them at a glance it
is also expected that apple glasses will
allow for some sort of navigation use
maybe you'll see a small map on one of
the lenses or
you might see text-based directions like
turn left and five feet considering the
unique role of apple glass
apple might even introduce a dedicated
app store like they have done with the
apple watch
and apple tv this might even allow you
to play games on the apple glass
but i'm not quite sure how engaging and
fun this will actually be
another major feature that apple watch
might sport is some sort of night vision
technology
if you've seen apple's latest night
vision technology with the iphone 12
you know it's quite amazing and with
apple glass
this technology would be more functional
than ever before
there are also rumors that apple glass
may have a speaker system
which would limit the need for airpods
but i'm not quite convinced
i think any speakers apple is working on
for a face-based wearable
is for an apple beer headset not for
apple glass
finally apple glass will likely also
have a plethora of super cool marketable
features that you will likely never use
like lidar with the iphone considering
all of this
apple glass will basically just be an
apple watch for your face
that supports some of our features and
will help you see better in the day
and night but how much will they
actually cost
many rumors are actually suggesting that
it will start at just 500
plus an extra fee to add your
prescription which coming from apple is
quite surprising
google charged 1500 nearly a decade ago
so i personally expected a price of at
least 999
plus prescription cost apple has been
making a lot of changes
over the past couple of years though so
500 may not fully be off the table
recently apple has primarily focused on
preserving their customer base
as opposed to expanding their customer
base thus apple might price the glasses
at 500
to lock in as many people as they can
into the apple ecosystem
after all most of the processing for the
apple glass will likely take place on
the iphone
so you can't really use apple glass
without an iphone
anyways moving on to release date some
rumors suggest that apple is already
ready to launch the glasses
and that they're simply waiting for an
in-person keynote opportunity to
announce the glasses
however most rumors suggest that apple
glass will likely come out in 2022
or 2023 in any case they're coming out
very soon
unlike the apple car and that brings us
into the key question will apple glass
flop well at first glance it might seem
excessive
and completely unnecessary and it is
but that doesn't mean apple glass will
perform poorly by any means
several years ago many people said the
exact same thing about the apple watch
the apple watch launched with a starting
price of 350
which was over double the price of the
most popular company smart watches
at the time it seemed like spending so
much money on an apple branded smart
watch was never going to catch on
but in 2021 here we are similarly
airpods were heavily ridiculed at launch
for being overpriced wireless headphones
but today it seems like everyone has
airpods
as you can see apple has successfully
interests massive changes
time and time again so it wouldn't be
wise to underestimate apple
with that being said let's take a look
at why google glass failed
to begin with one of the most
significant shortfalls of google glass
was how it looked it had a super big
tempo and
didn't even have lenses for both eyes it
simply had a tiny little holographic
screen
at the top right corner needless to say
you definitely wouldn't fit in if you're
wearing this in public
but google was okay with that they were
trying to embrace the inner nerd within
all of us
however most people were clearly not
interested in wearing this contraption
in public people generally don't like to
attract attention
in public especially not unwanted
attention
so it's essential that apple glass looks
just like regular glasses
ideally people shouldn't even be able to
recognize that you're even wearing smart
glasses
looking at the renderings based on leaks
and considering that this is apple
it looks like they should be good in
this category aside from looking funky
google glass didn't really provide a
seamless experience google glass was
supposed to combine the virtual world
and the real world but all it really did
was constantly put a screen in front of
your face
this could be explained by the fact that
google glass didn't actually use ar
technology
google glass literally just had an lcd
screen that was transparent
apple on the other hand has apparently
been working on aero technology for
years
so let's hope it's actually practical
and not intrusive
moving on another major concern is
battery life
customers who buy apple glass will
likely be looking for it to replace the
regular glasses
and with apple class we know that the
optical sub assembly will allow for the
glasses to accommodate for the user's
prescription
and their specific eye distance and all
of that the concern here
is that the optical subassembly is
controlled by an integrated processor
so will the prescription stop working
once apple glass runs out of battery
life
i'm not sure but if that's the case that
would no doubt significantly reduce
practicality as users will have to carry
around backup glasses or contacts
even if that's not the case though apple
will have to nail battery life
i'm pretty sure that people don't want
to charge their glasses in the middle of
the day
at the same time i'm also pretty sure
that people actually want the smart
functionality that they are paying for
to work all day
so all-day battery life will be
essential in promoting large-scale
adoption
fortunately 12 or 14-hour battery life
wouldn't actually be required to make
this possible
most of the processing will be done on
your phone and your glasses won't
actually be displaying something
most of the time so most users should be
able to get a full day's worth of views
with battery life that can support five
to six hours worth of screen time
if the apple glass only supports three
to four hours of battery life though
apple will likely have problems another
major concern that apple will have to
address
is privacy one of the top criticisms of
google glass
was that it had a camera that could
record everything that the user was
seeing
not only did this make many users
uncomfortable as google glass was
capable of recording the inside of their
house
and private conversations but this also
made people around these individuals
uncomfortable
as well as you can't tell if someone is
recording you while wearing google glass
to prevent any privacy concerns
regarding apple glass it's best if apple
does not include a camera
at all on the glasses finally that
brings me on to my final criteria that
apple must meet with their glasses to
succeed
which is a unique offering apple glasses
must offer something that other apple
devices do not
offer by themselves for instance the
apple watch is extremely popular within
the fitness community
as it allows users to track their
workouts without their iphone bouncing
around in their pockets
mac computers are extremely popular
amongst creative professionals
as the software integration is nearly
flawless and airpods are extremely
popular
across the board as they give users a
seamless headphone experience
similarly apple glass must offer a
unique advantage to a broad group of
people for it to really catch on
in other words it can't just be an
alternative to looking down
at your phone in my opinion a lack of
unique functionality
is the fundamental reason that google
glass failed it was super cool
technology and all
but it didn't offer anything that you
couldn't do by just using your phone
or better yet glancing at your smart
watch maybe the unique offering is being
able to see better in the dark
or being able to utilize augmented
reality to its fullest imagine being
able to visualize any product you want
to buy
on your desk or being able to try on new
outfits by looking
at a mirror a lot of this technology
already exists on our phone
but it definitely makes much more sense
in combination with smart glasses
as long as apple is able to meet all of
these criteria i think apple glasses
will actually be a success
and you might have noticed that i left
our price from this equation
apple has proven their ability to sell
arguably overpriced products very well
time and time again and as long as apple
glass
isn't priced like the apple monitor
stand at 5 000 or something absurd like
that
price shouldn't be an obstacle if apple
glass is priced between 500 and 2 000
and it meets all their criteria people
might complain about it
at first but i think most will
eventually come around to it
as we've seen historically do you guys
think apple glass will fail
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys are excited for smart
glasses to hopefully finally be done
right
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions lastly answered but until then
i'm hari i'll see you guys on the next
one
you